[Music]
she's a heartbeat away from leading the
nation but her staffers say here's my
resignation
yep they're just too embarrassed to keep
working for kamala harris
with her approval rating so in the
toilet you need roto-rooter to find them
she's losing one more high-profile
staffer but that's what happens when
you're known as joe biden's number two
see you try to get me to stop doing poop
jokes
but they won't let me stop the poop
jokes come from me simone sanders no
relation to the colonel
is quitting as senior adviser and chief
spokeswoman
and like your savings administration
officials say she'll be gone at the end
of the year
simone is the second high-profile
staffer to leave the vp in recent weeks
the first was her communications
director ashley etienne her staff turns
over more than dog the bounty hunter at
a tanning salon
which is a lot
this is such big news we needed to get
the vice president's comment on the
matter i caught up with the vice
president earlier today
so madam vice president welcome back to
the show
thanks uh i was hoping to be on with
that timf girl though this time because
it's crazy how someone could be so funny
smart
and good-looking at the same time true
but she is a violent drunk
anyway let's get to the topic because i
know you're busy yeah uh i'm actually
not that busy in case you haven't
noticed i'm a
toaster
true true but your chief spokeswoman
just resigned why
it's pretty easy short pants the
couldn't hack it excuse me you heard me
fart breath she couldn't be around a
strong woman of color like me
but she's also a strong woman of color
exactly you
idiot but you're a toaster
don't you know last week she tried to
throw me into a bathtub full of water
really
are you calling me a liar squatty body
no i just find it hard to believe she
tried to kill you i bet if i were white
you'd believe me typical stupid white
cracker
well thanks for coming on
and congrats on the ring
you know uh kat uh that's an amazing job
um
you know because we can't actually do an
impersonation of kamal harris i would be
racist
so uh
we're just using a toaster from now on
and i think it really worked it must be
hard though to work for a bad boss you
don't have that problem
[Laughter]
i think
it would be hard to be a spokesperson in
general yes i would never want to be a
spokesperson
i would like to have
a spokesperson yes like you you know you
do something bad yeah just call him up
like hey spokesperson
what are you gonna do about it
and then they have to like come up with
a strategy and then put on nice clothes
and go talk to all the people that i
pissed off yes they can ask them
questions about it so the people that i
pissed off when they think of my
they'll remember the spokesperson's face
and not mine there you go that's how it
works i want a spokesperson but i don't
want to be a spokesperson one day one
day that'll happen uh loftus um
can you blame them for jumping ship what
if it's them and not her what if sanders
leaves and suddenly she gets better like
uh uh commonly gets better that's not
gonna happen
there's like zero chance it'll feel like
the next person will get sick and tired
of kamala harris no one likes this chick
like no one wants to be around she it's
like a if politics was a potluck dinner
she's that nasty dish that no one wants
to eat but someone keeps bringing it
someone keeps showing up no no that's a
very interesting analogy that you have i
would have said like if if she were a
fashion plate
it would be she would be your jacket
[Laughter]
no because the jacket's cool
and people love the jacket
it's definitely
i think you slept in it yeah that's how
you that's how you break it in it's like
a baseball glove you put it under your
pillow you sleep with this and a couple
fifths of jack daniels there you go
thank you by the way
yeah but kamala harris she though she
knows she's the butternut squash
spaghetti
of potluck
now you're stepping into my zone buddy i
like that butternut squash
i had great butternut squash soup today
from hale and hardy it was delicious no
oh someone is obviously doing mind
control that doesn't exist
all right joey um what if it what if
we're wrong what if she's like trump
she's just hard to work with if you just
let her be herself she'll be amazing
at least
[Laughter]
laughing in my face
literally no really though here's the
thing
i heard they're leaving for like jobs
that have a future like for best buy or
blockbuster something that might be
around in a year circuit city yeah
so yeah and so here's the problem
they're in communications her numbers
are in the tank yes i don't know that
she isn't so arrogant that she is
actually telling them that you're not
doing a good enough job and you need to
leave i mean that may actually be where
it is but you know her best was when she
was in the senate and she was kind of
this bulldog character on everyone they
brought in they rolled in there and she
was interrogated yeah and she's not
doing that as vice president which is
ironic because that's kind of the vice
president's job right especially when
you have someone like biden that you're
like hey bro you're awake over there
yeah you need someone like her to bring
that personality and the fact they're
not using that is really odd to me like
i don't understand the political
strategy behind it yeah she just stands
behind him like she's his nurse it's
weird yeah which i mean
she's not doing anything else
you're you're kind of an insider dude
what's your what's the what's the
scuttle butt um so you have to remember
that no one thought that joe biden was
going to be president at the start of
this either so i think that kamala as
much as the numbers are terrible as much
as she was the borders are who's no
longer the borders are even though
there's no official announcement about
why that's the case she probably sees
this and says if joe can do it literally
anyone can i think the part of this that
is a surprise is the guy who is
cognitively declining in front of people
and you're worried if he's going to walk
out sometime and just start saying
gibberish is actually better on the
optics than kamala showing up and trying
to be normal and friendly and appealing
to people yeah that's what i think
people didn't expect in this
administration and there's no way to
turn that around i got it completely
wrong i thought that she was going to
like learn on the job she ticked all the
boxes so she all she has to do is like
be normal and she couldn't do that i
remember when she though that the best
was when she at one of the debates was
like well i'm clearly a top-tier
candidate yeah and everybody who
followed politics was like actually no
but she thought she was when you have to
pay chil children to act to like you
you know you got a problem nobody known
for their nervous cackle is ever going
to appear to be normal right like she
doesn't appear to be normal she can at
least just be mean at least that's an
emotion
i respect the genuine mean
exactly it's true just go mean if nobody
likes you already and you're laughing
and having a good time
drop that stuff and just be an
you know what i think that was in the
bible